it adds a lot of friction to the process
but but I believe that over time this is
going to help build a more trustworthy
platform is going to and is going to be
better for everyone all right third
we're also building out a lot of deep
technical infrastructure and replumb the
whole infrastructure that we build for
this company to support this privacy
vision so it was an example of this in
our systems today are already built to
know who can who's allowed to author
who's authorized to see you know the
photos that you post for examples that
way you know someone who's not supposed
to see it tries to access it on Facebook
we can block them but now what we're
also developing infrastructure that can
that knows how certain types of data are
allowed to be used so it can
automatically block unauthorized uses in
our infrastructure and prevent errors
now like a lot of other internet
companies out there you know we rely on
engineers today to manually code a lot
of these access rules into our systems
but we think that we can make this more
reliable and more secure so we're
looking at ways in in future computer
languages and in future databases and
systems that can encode privacy and data
use principles as first-class concepts
across our whole infrastructure and this
is there's gonna take a long time the
infrastructure is very complex but this
is just one of the way is that we're
replumb increased ruk sure for for what
we do to support this privacy vision all
right so overall this is this isn't just
about a few new features sorry this is a
big change in how we're building these
products and how we run our company it's
not gonna happen overnight and to be
clear we don't have all the answers for
how this is gonna work yet but today we
are ready to start talking about parts
of what this privacy focused vision is
going to look like across each of the
areas that we're building so let's start
with our messaging apps which is going
to be the foundation of this vision now
the first thing that we've got to
deliver for all of you is the best
private messaging
Ariane's by far right and then on top of
that we can start building more ways to
interact privately but the first thing
that we need to do is deliver a basic
messaging experience which is the
fastest simplest most reliable and and
most secure of any of the leading
platforms out there
so for messenger we've been focused on
rewriting the entire thing from scratch
to deliver the best private messaging
experience that there is and last year
at f8 we introduced the first step of
this our new very simple design m4 that
was step one and now our next goal is to
make messenger the fastest messaging app
out there and to make the app binary
size smaller than than any of the major
social apps so we've been working on a
project that we've called Lightspeed and
we've been working on this for a long
time to rewrite the whole thing and now
we're a few months away from starting to
roll this out and here are some some
early benchmarks from from our lab
looking out fast this is compared to the
other leading platforms out there
generally whatsapp is is faster than
than the other leading platforms but the
other thing that we showed was was
basically the average of the leading
messaging platforms in each country
around the world and and and Lightspeed
is just going to be much faster all
right so that's what we're doing on
simplicity and speed to be the most
reliable though you know you need to do
more than just deliver the messages
consistently but we need to make sure
that the service is available everywhere
that you are and for a modern messaging
experience that means having a great
desktop experience so we've built a
great new desktop app certain built a
chat and video chat
and it native app not just not just the
browser this we're launching this on
both Mac and Windows and this is this is
one of our our top most requested
features all right so that privacy and
security so we believe that a privacy
focused messaging platform has to be
encrypted so we actually launched secret
conversations a couple of years ago so
you can already have encrypted and
ephemeral conversations if you want but
now we're working towards making intend
encryption and reduced permanence the
default across all conversations and
when we do this across both messenger
and whatsapp we're going to enable more
than 2 billion people around the world
to have their most personal
conversations with each other privately
without having to worry about hackers
governments or even us being able to see
what you're saying so I think that this
is just going to be a historically
important step for privacy around the
world
so with this foundation the fastest
experience available everywhere with the
strongest privacy and security now let's
take a look at how a private social
platform can start to become the center
of your social experience so as an
example and we're launching a friend's
tab in messenger and over time you're
going to see what your friends are
sharing with you across our different
apps so if you follow someone on
Instagram you'll be able to see their
stories if you're friends with someone
on Facebook you love to see their their
posts and their stories and it's gonna
be all private updates from friends no
no public content and and this starts to
give you just a sense of what is
possible with interoperability between
services and how a private platform can
start to be more central to how you
interact with friends it also continues
the trend that we've seen with stories
were following conversations are
happening in private messages rather
than public comment threads more and
more all right we're also making video
chat a lot better we're launching the
ability to Co watch videos with your
friends and this is the an example of
how video chat which is just growing
really quickly
is one of the basic ways that we all
communicate privately can start to
become more of a platform for how for
more of the ways that we would want to
interact privately with each other
alright so now let's let's move over and
talk about whatsapp so whatsapp already
has incredibly strong privacy and
performance so here we're more focused
on the next step which is building out
all of the ways that you would want to
interact in the digital living room
so first is status right and this is
just the most popular ephemeral stories
product in the world even bigger than
what we're doing with Instagram and one
of the reasons for this is that it's
completely focused on delivering a
private and intimate experience it's all
people you know there are no public
figure accounts that you can follow and
it's not encrypted so we don't even see
the content of the of the statuses that
you post now there's more to do here we
want to make sure that the experience
continues to be focused on your closest
friends and family and not just
whichever of your contacts happens to
share the most so we're working on a way
is to do more ranking of the content on
the client side which as we move more of
our systems to be encrypted that kind of
work is going to be increasingly
important across all of our apps over
time we've also built some ways to share
your location privately in real time and
you know I use this for example with my
family and my friends when when we go
skiing together and you know we
architected this feature so your
location data is is encrypted so our
servers actually never see your location
as they're sharing it with your friends
it's it's very privacy protective what's
up business is also a big focus within a
year millions of small businesses around
the world are using this to communicate
privately with their customers and and
now we're launching a new feature for
this product catalogs so you're gonna be
able to easily see what is available
from a business and now this is gonna be
especially important for all of the the
small businesses out there that don't
have a web presence and that are
increasingly using private social
platforms is their main way of
interacting
with their customers alright so let's
talk about payments because this is a
part of the vision that I'm particularly
excited about because when I look out at
all the different ways that people
interact privately I think payments in
is one of the areas where we have an
opportunity to make it a lot easier
that's among the most important things
that we can do here I believe that it
should be as easy to send money to
someone as it is to send a photo so
we're already testing this in India with
about a million people it's it's being
used a lot and the feedback so far is
great and we're already working on
rolling this out and a number of other
countries later this year and you can
you can take a look at what the basic
experiences and overall payments and
private commerce is one of the areas
that I'm really excited about and we're
gonna have a lot more news and things to
talk about here over the the coming year
as we flush this out more so these are
just a few examples of some of the
experiences that we're gonna be able to
build here and and it's a look at how
we're starting to bring this privacy
focused vision to life now I start off
today talking about how we all want to
be able to communicate both publicly and
privately so now let's turn to Facebook
and Instagram the digital town squares
because as we focus more on privacy
across our whole company we're also
focusing on adding more ways to interact
privately across these apps as well and
here we're focusing on groups we're
focusing on stories and more private
ways to interact with businesses now a
couple of years ago we changed our whole
mission as a company to focus on on
helping you build community all right
and the idea here is that our friends
and family are always going to be the
core of our social lives but we also
need to belong to communities that that
share our values and interests that that
support us that help us give us that
sense of purpose and and that help us
grow in the ways that we want and you
know I think that this matters even more
today than before because in a world
where people
joining fewer physical communities and
there's less social cohesion it's more
important than ever to make it so that
we can easily be a part of communities
that are meaningful to us now there are
already more than 400 million people who
are members of Facebook groups that that
are meaningful to them and that are
among the most important parts of their
social experience and these are groups
typically where people get together
physically in person as well as online
all right like this small group for
people who like running and also care
about the environment so they get
together and go running and pick up
trash on their town or like this
tight-knit group for military families
so and when they get deployed to a new
city they know where to go to ask what
what school to send their kids to and
how to get integrated into the local
community and we believe that there is a
community for everyone so we've been
working on a major evolution to redesign
the the Facebook app to make communities
as central as friends now in the history
of Facebook there have been four major
versions of the product so far and and
this is the fifth so we're calling this
FB 5 and it has a much bigger focus on
communities and making communities as
central as friends so here's a look at
what this is going to look like it's a
it's got a much cleaner look and feel
for the app it puts your private groups
right at the center of the experience
and it's a it's a much lighter design
overall the app isn't even blue anymore
[Music]
all right now while we're at it we were
also rewriting the Facebook website
completely from scratch and redesigning
it to make it much faster and cleaner as
well this one is coming a little later
this year but but here's a preview of
what its gonna look like now across both
of these there's a lot of new work
under the hood right and this is more
the the the the sum of hundreds of
details rather than just a few major
changes but overall we've made it a lot
easier to find and connect to the groups
that you're gonna be interested in much
better suggestions better browse and
discover tools there's a new groups tab
that puts all of your communities in one
place overall
basically now everywhere where you're
going to be able to see and connect with
your friends you're also going to be
able to see and connect with groups that
you care about and it all adds up to
this feeling that groups are now at the
heart of the experience just as much as
your friends and family are now while
we're doing this we are very focused on
unsafety here across groups and you know
while we're recommending groups for
people to join we're very focused on
making sure there are recommendations
and discovery surfaces aren't
highlighting groups where people are
repeatedly sharing misinformation or
harmful content and we're working hard
to completely remove groups if they
exist primarily due to violate our
policies or or do things that are
dangerous so that's just been a very big
focus for us here now there's also a lot
more to communities than just groups and
there are lots of different ways to to
interact with the people in the
communities that you care about a lot of
them are private around events around
games around dating or other ways to
meet new people there's a lot more to to
fb5
and in Fiji is gonna come out a bit
later to walk you through all this and
in more detail but but overall you know
this is the biggest change to the
Facebook app and website that we've made
in the last five years since we made the
whole thing native and and and a lot
faster and it was a symbol of this you
know we're not just updating the look
and feel we're also updating the
Facebook icon and refreshing it for the
first time since since I can remember to
make it a bit more lively and modern so
there we go and I'm excited to get this
app in all of your hands we're shipping
this today and
so we're gonna start rolling it out and
and everyone and everyone in the u.s. is
gonna be able to get it today and a
couple of other places and we're gonna
roll it out across the the rest of the
world over the coming weeks as well so
all right now for for Instagram let's
move on to Instagram we are we were also
very focused on on adding more private
private interactions to what is
generally a a course staple of our
digital town square here and and here at
Instagram we're mostly focused on
stories which are generally more privacy
protective since they're more ephemeral
than then posting into to feed
permanently and we're also focused on
payments and interacting with private
interactions with businesses so let's
start with shopping
you know one of the interesting
challenges with shopping either online
or offline is that a lot of the way that
we browse is is in public but then when
we actually go to do a transaction
that's a very private interaction so we
think that there's an opportunity with
Instagram to marry these two experiences
together and make them both better now
what we know that a lot of us sort of
use Instagram to find things that we're
interested in and and we think that
there's an opportunity to do just a lot
more here so we were launching today a
new shopping channel and explore still
gonna be able to browse things that you
may want to buy or interested in we are
we're continuing to roll out checkout as
you're gonna be able to buy from more
and more brands from directly within the
app and we're also announcing that we're
adding a new way for people to buy
directly from creators too so that means
that you're gonna be able to support the
people who are making the stuff that you
love and I think that's gonna be a
pretty big deal all right now moving
along to stories you know as more of our
sharing moves to stories and becomes
more ephemeral and impermanent we're
building more features on top of stories
as well and and there are two that that
I'm that I'm excited to talk about today
the first is that we're making the
camera a lot better we're we're adding a
new create mode we're calling it which
makes it so that when
building a story or starting a story you
don't need to start with a photo or a
video anymore you can start by just
bringing a stickers or drawing or
putting text so that's a pretty big
change to how stories has worked so far
we're also launching donation stickers
so you're gonna be able to create
fundraisers an Instagram for causes that
are important to you and that you care
about and this is another example of a
feature that is going to benefit from
greater interoperability between these
different networks so you can reach with
the fundraisers that you create all of
the different people you you know across
our different apps all right now we've
mostly talked so far about our mobile
apps and what's possible to build in the
unfolds in the current generation of
computing but we're also very focused on
building technology to shape the next
generation of computing to make it more
human more designed around the ways that
we all naturally interact with each
other and and now also more aligned with
this privacy focused vision for the
future so I think that that augmented
and virtual reality have the potential
to create much more personal and
intimate experiences with VR you feel
like you're actually right there present
with someone even if physically they're
there they're in a completely different
place somewhere halfway across the world
and where they are you know instead of
you having your face and your phone and
someone else having their face and
there's you know now the computing
environment is going to put digital
objects in the real world they're gonna
be able to both interact with it and
actually be present together so two
years ago at f8 we talked about how the
camera was gonna be the first AR
platform and in the last year alone more
than a billion people have used AR
features on Facebook Instagram messenger
and portal and now to make this into an
even broader platform we're focused on
making it easier to build for so today
we're announcing
we were bringing the spark a our studio
and we're supporting both Windows and
Mac and we are also going to open our AR
beta for Instagram so everyone is gonna
be able to build for it now that one of
my favorite uses of AR so far I have to
say this on portal now if if any of you
have kids or you know if seen kids using
masks or story time on portal you
probably know what I mean this is this
is a photo of my mom reading three
little pigs to my daughters and portal
has turned her into a wolf as she's
huffing and puffing so this is one of
the reasons that then I think portal has
done better than we expected right it
helps people feel together and and have
these intimate experiences even when you
can't physically be together you can
feel like you're together so building on
this I'm excited to announce that we are
going to launch portal internationally
we're starting in Canada and June and
we're going to be rolling it out across
a number of countries in Europe coming
later this fall and as part of this of
course it's really important that we
bring whatsapp to portal so we're doing
that so now you're gonna be able to to
make video calls on both whatsapp and
messenger on portal and you know what
that means that means that we are
bringing end-to-end encryption to all
video calls on portal so now you can be
sure that when you're having
conversations with your friends and
family everything stays between you
all right now the last area that I want
to talk about today is virtual reality
now this is gonna be a big year for VR
because we are shipping two new products
oculus rift s which improves on the
original rift a higher resolution
display better optics inside out
tracking and of course we're launching
oculus quest the all-in-one headset that
we've all been waiting for with no
cables and full freedom of movement so
you know these these are a real step
forward or if test is the most powerful
VR headset that you can buy and quest
quest just blows people away because
it's the first time you can just walk
around a VR space and fully interact
with the people in it so I'm excited to
announce that we're opening pre-orders
for both of them today they're each
going to be 399 they're gonna start
shipping within a month on May 21st
and that's a date that you're all gonna
want to remember because everyone here
at f8 is going to be getting a free
oculus
so
so I'm really excited to get this into
your hands I can't wait to hear I can't
wait to hear what you all think of this
it's I'm excited to hear what you all
think and and to see you all post videos
of how exciting it is as you're using
this
alright so okay so you know that's um so
that's how we're starting to build out
this privacy focused vision across
everything we do it's still early but if
we get this right then using all of
these services is going to be a
fundamentally different experience a few
years from now now at the end of the day
this isn't just about building some new
products it's a major shift in how we
run this company because we believe that
for the future
people want a privacy focused social
platform and I believe that if we build
out a fully encrypted interoperable
service with all of the ways that people
want to interact privately then that's
gonna be an important contribution to
the world now for us this is about
building the kind of future that we want
to live in I believe that we should be
working to build a world where we can be
ourselves and where we can live freely
knowing that that our private moments
we're only gonna be seen by the people
we want a world where everyone has the
power to speak and say what they want
and use their voice and connect to the
people that care about where we can come
together around community and around
commerce where we build in the tools
that we need to keep us safe from the
beginning and and prevent harm and while
we're we then are able to focus on all
the good that people are able to do and
not just the big moments or the social
movements the breakthroughs but also all
the everyday good the emotional support
that the jokes with friends that feeling
of being together with your family both
in private and in public the living room
and our town squares
so if we work hard and deliver this
vision that we've laid out today and I'm
going to be proud of the difference that
we've made so thank you all looking
forward to doing this together and have
a great faith